i used to wear glasses glasses but i
wore glasses so long in my life that i
decided i
just didn't want to wear them anymore so
how do you see i just i have one bad eye
i just look through the other one
[Music]
what's up gq this is jack harlow and
these are my 10 essentials
great 990s i think it's one of the
greatest silhouettes in shoe history
my dad wore new balances like a lot of
dads growing up
but in high school i started wearing new
balance not a lot of kids in louisville
were wearing new balance at the time you
know it's kind of bigger on the east
coast like the dmv
i just wanted to wear something
different and i liked the way they felt
so i just kind of ran with it
and now it's a little more official and
i'm working with them
and i'll probably get a new pair of
these from
new balance once a month i'm not really
even a sneaker head
to be honest i don't love shoes that
much i have a few pairs that
i'm not gonna wear to a concert or if i
knew i was gonna be walking in grass
but these i wear them anywhere these are
being mass produced
it's just a great shoe it's classic it
can go with a lot of things and this is
the type of thing i put on with a
sweatsuit
in the middle of night and go on a
mission yeah i wear these constantly i
mean this is a shoe i would tap into the
rest of my life
about a year ago i probably wouldn't
been able to bring as many things in
here because
you know i don't have a lot of items i
feel like i can't live without i'm not
materialistic but
i got this recently and i'm in love with
it it's a sky dweller stainless steel
rolex
i like the color of it i don't really
like yellow gold so for me this can go
with so much
in the blue face like i mean especially
right now this hits right now just
because of my fit but
i didn't fantasize about watches growing
up but now that i have one i really
could see myself building a collection
but it's the only watch i have right now
so these are condoms i really like the
grip on them
and they're just effective your life can
go downhill without them so
i really recommend these where can you
buy them a lot of places
pharmacies grocery stores you know it
gets tougher
the later at night it gets but there's a
lot of options most places most places
carry them
there's a chance i can't live without
them it's an essential at all times
all locations so next
i have these i got these about six days
ago
i really like how they fit my face
there's no brand name on them
so i have no idea what brand they are my
friend urban gave them to me
i can hide behind them in a way at the
right times you know it gives me a nice
like an anonymous feel
like when i just want to take a walk and
just be amongst society
sometimes i get recognized in them but a
lot of times i can slide with these
and just and i feel good behind them and
i've seen myself in them and i like how
it looks
my air purifier part of me thinks that
it's been
placebo for me that this is making my
air better but
it feels like my area has been better
since i got this
yeah i haven't changed this filter yet
so i could be breathing in
dusty ass air no telling there have been
no alerts on it
so i feel like it lasts a while and i
like the size of it just looks like it
has an effect on the room
sometimes i turn it on blast and it's
just
this is a ring i got this about three
weeks ago the championship ring and i
got eight of them for my entire
collective private garden that's what it
says on the front
and uh this was a special moment this
was the first time i really iced out
my collective and the guys i came up
with it's just a lot of diamonds on my
face
and some white gold and some enamel
there's a fountain on the front
fountains our logo alex moss designed it
out of new york
it's similar to the watch i never
thought i would be a ring guy but
i just love wearing it i love how i feel
in it
i was in the gym maybe eight months ago
and there was a woman in the gym
selling cmos and one of the main things
she told me about it is that it
increases your libido
and just your drive and she gave me some
right there and the rest of time i was
in the gym
horny as hell i was turnt up i couldn't
even really work out i had to go home
and it has a lot of other benefits
immune system support stuff like that
i think it's in one of those like
rainbow blossom type expensive
chips with a bland bag type you know i
don't know one of those stories i don't
think these are
like they might be a kroger but i don't
know i think it's at one of those nice
stores
i think it's good for your body and i
take a lot of it
white tee i got a drawer these and i
wear them
at least every other day i like the way
these fit these are the slim fit calvin
kleins
and they really grip me and make me look
fit i don't spill things
i haven't spilled anything since i was
like 14. i love wearing white
i wear white all the time i think it's
my favorite color to wear i wear all
white
my pants are white right now white shirt
you know i love white
so these are scissors i use these to cut
a lot of things
tags um there's certain chip bags
like let's talk about the veggie sticks
because i knew this was gonna come up
let's just talk about it the bag is like
it's just like it's not built for a man
to open
and it's so stupid because when you do
cut it open then how do they stay fresh
you have to eat the whole bag right
there because
then it's just a torn bag and then you
can't so i'll open a bag with this
regretfully but i do use these to open
certain like sturdy chip bags
no i wouldn't trust myself to cut my
hair i've never even shaved myself
my mind i've shaved myself
i have this hoodie can you read it it
says ear ecstasy on it
i don't have any article i've had longer
than this i keep it tucked in my closet
i don't take a lot of places because i
would be devastated if i lost it and
it's one of the few items i have that i
feel that way about
so your ex sees a record store that was
around in the city i'm from louisville
kentucky when i was in middle school it
was right at the end of the cd era we
used to go up to the store and
we would buy jones soda and we would buy
cds and it was just a special place and
it's really a landmark in louisville
history for sure somehow it still fits
me i've grown a lot since middle school
it was big on me then and now it's small
on me now but it's always work so
i treasure this for real
[Music]
gq thank you so much for having me i had
a great time
i'm jack carlo and those were my
essentials